you
hello everyone and welcome today's live
webinars choroid plexus epithelial cell
2d and modified 3d cell culture model is
presented by dr. Elizabeth delery
postdoctoral fellow department of
physiology Louisiana State University
Health Sciences Center
I'm Christie Joel of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars
presenter my lab roots and it's brought
to you by thermo Fisher Scientific to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit thermo Fisher com forward slash
cell culture heroes
now let's get started I'd like to inform
everyone that today's webinar is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for it at
the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of your presentation window or you can
let us know you're having a problem by
using the ask a question box at the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and the suppers continuing
education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I now
present today's speaker dr. Elizabeth of
delery postdoctoral fellow Department of
physiology Louisiana State University
Health Sciences Center for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. delery you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Christy hello everyone thank
you for joining me today my name is dr.
Elizabeth Bellary and today I will be
presenting my choroid plexus epithelial
cell 2d and modified 3d cell culture
model so today this is my overview and
what I'm going through just a little bit
about me a little bit about HIV and then
reading into why I wanted to look at the
choroid plexus is just a little bit
about that just for background for those
of you that aren't aware of it as well
as moving into how I designed the 2d
cell culture and then how it created my
modified 3d model so about me as I said
before my name is Elizabeth and I'm a
postdoc in the physiology department at
Louisiana State University Health
Sciences Center currently I study the
neurobiology of alcohol opioids and pain
I attended randolph college for my
undergraduate studies where i majored in
biology and psychology with a pre-med
concentration
it was while I was here that I was first
introduced to research as you can see
from the little blue square in the
bottom left I worked in the biology
department where I studied soil soil
characteristics are most area innocuous
survival and growth and the psychology
department actually looked at various
exercises and social activities on
cortisol levels and expression so I
really decided that undergrad really
introduced me to research and wanting to
figure things out so my professors
encouraged me to go on and pursue my PhD
I was accepted to Tulane University
School of Medicine and biomedical
sciences ph.d program and I completed my
PhD at Tulane National Primate Research
Center my dissertation was actually on
the choroid plexus and HIV pathogenesis
and I just graduated this past spring
in my free time my husband and I like to
go on adventures and we have two very
rambunctious dogs wishbone which is on
the left and then sort who's a little
goofball on the right
also in my free time I run an Instagram
page where I like to talk about science
I like science communication because I
like to help fight the internet
pseudoscience that's out there well
showing that science is fun and get
people excited to learn about it I also
want to break the scientists stereotype
that we're always in the lab and that
we're really boring that we don't have
lives outside of science and then I also
like to promote inclusion in STEM
whether it's race sex orientation
disability etc and here are some
examples of some goofy post has posted
the one on the left I was talking about
eyeballs and how we see with some super
goofy eyeball glasses and the other one
was a maternity photo shoot I took with
my dissertation because it took me about
nine months to write so let's start
talking about my research so just in
general a little background on the HIV
epidemic in 2017 there were thirty six
point nine million people living with
HIV in the world that around 1.8 million
new diagnoses and just shy of 1 million
deaths from HIV related disorders in
2017 so it's still a very pertinent
global health issue in the United States
dc50 for too far for in the United
States DC has the highest percentage of
new cases of HIV in the United States
and then Louisiana which is a state that
I currently live is is actually in the
fourth place with twenty two point one
new diagnoses per 100,000 people so
still very close to home and a very
important issue for me living in
Louisiana so some primary obstacles to
curing HIV are the presence of long
lived by reservoirs now these reservoirs
can persist despite the use of long term
combination antiretroviral therapy which
is the drugs we use to treat HIV and
that's combination two or more drugs
taken at the same time the brain is one
of these long-lived viral reservoirs
this was my background at Randolph was
biology and psychology degree really
wanted to focus on the brain and figure
out what was going on in
I issues with the brain being a
reservoir so when HIV infects the brain
it leads to a series of disorders known
as HIV associated neurocognitive
disorders there are three different
levels and here's a list of diagnostic
criteria on how to identify as you can
see of asymptomatic which is more mild
and has the prevalence percentages
unless the center column is around 30%
an S in a combination antiretroviral
treated hiv-positive individuals you
also have mild which is a slightly more
severe type and then the most severe is
actually HIV associated dementia
collectively this disorder these
disorders are known as hand episode of
just little name form acronym for them
so HIV is believed to enter the central
nervous system when infected monocytes
or macrophages are unknowingly
trafficked across the central nervous
system via Trojan horse a trojan herd
model a Trojan horse model argues that a
few infected monocytes and macrophages
enter the central nervous system and
they establish a latent infection in the
brain while the trojan heard my model
argues there's little like there's a
surge of infected modified macrophages
into the central nervous system late in
infection towards the progression to
AIDS either way when central HIV enters
the central nervous system it can lead
to these disorders so pathologically HIV
when we're looking at like the the
actual slides of brain tissue
neuropathology includes lesion
perivascular cuffing luke acidic
infiltrates and the presence of
multinucleated giant cells which are
these giant cells that are result of
macrophages fusing together in chronic
inflammation whether it's a failure
division or whatever they just make
these gigantic cells and as you can see
on the left I just have an example of an
H and E of one that two of the vets at
the primate center took it's kind of
towards the top area this big circle
with a lot of blue nuclei around it our
purple circle with a blue nuclei around
and that's your multinucleated giant
cells and for a better example on the
right
this is an immunofluorescent image of a
multinucleated giant so it's pretty much
dead center in the picture and it's a
green circle with the blue Dappy nuclei
around it the grain is CD 163 a
macrophage market because again these
cells are formed from macrophages so in
doing a literature review to learn more
about hiv-associated neurocognitive
disorders i began to focus on the
choroid plexus which is the blood
cerebrospinal fluid barrier CSF barrier
a place where HIV infected cells can
enter the central nervous system and
it's been identified in the literature
as being none of the reservoirs and also
been identified as being an area of
productive infectious as well so the
core is Lexus limes the lateral third
and fourth ventricles in the brain which
is like a space surrounding the brain as
you can see kind of like the inner side
of the brain a Carolee point but you've
got the arrow in the top right as you
can see right below arachnoid you see
the choroid plexus in the center kind of
of the skull
it produces the cereal here's a better
picture of it how it lines the actual
ventricles and it produces the
cerebrospinal fluid that protects the
brain and it's composed of these
fenestrated capillaries inside a neuron
devoid stroma surrounded by a single
layer of epithelial cell so that's how
you really identify it's kind of look
like this curly like broccoli almost but
because a single layer of epithelial
cells on the outside and that's really
how you can find it on the side it's
super super easy to spot once you know
you're what you're looking for so get
some more pictures you can get a better
idea of what it looks like this is kind
of a 3d representation of it as you can
see again I described it like broccoli
doesn't really look like broccoli but
he's got these protrusions that come off
of it so it's this 3d structure that's
kind of floating inside the ventricles
it's attached but flows out into the
cerebrospinal fluid that it produces
and then here is a better example of the
single epithelial cells followed by you
have the inside the fenestrated
capillaries on the inside it's got the
endothelial cells surrounding the
capillaries so for something to get into
the central nervous system and have to
first cross the endothelial cells of the
fenestrated capillaries it has to
encounter any immune cells inside of it
they're like macrophages in microglia
and then it will travel out through the
choroidal epithelium it allows for the
diffusion of water and sodium through to
maintain like water homeostasis in the
brain and it can also allow the movement
of larger molecules like glucose into
and out of the brain like I mentioned
before cells can traffic through the
choroid plexus and basically a normal
immune surveillance but you can have
increased movement in times of brain
damage
I can also prevent drugs or allow drugs
to enter the central nervous system
because it has multidrug-resistant
proteins to either block or allow drugs
from entering the central nervous system
so just for a brief history of a
background of the choroid plexus it was
first identified by her Ovilus way way
way back then in BC and he called it a
choroid concatenation Galen later in
like 130 to 200 AD first gave it its
true names coid plexuses
it was discovered in 1543 by ms alias
the choroid plexus produces
cerebrospinal fluid but it really wasn't
until the early 1900s that you started
at the detailed structure and morphology
you know with increased scientific
technology and microscopes we were able
to actually really see more about the
structure and how it set up in the brain
you want to know a little bit more about
this and just some background on it
Shayne littlelow has two really great
review papers that are actually really
interesting reads out there that just
the development of the choroid plexus
and the CSS barrier as well as just the
different barriers of the brain and just
how we've learned about it over time so
those are both very very great review
articles so you'd like to go back and
read more about this topic now I've been
boring you about the background research
you really want to know why why the
quarry plexus and why we want to focus
on this the choroid plexus is an adult
stem cell niche one of the locations has
been known to create neural progenitor
cells it's the interface between the
blood and the cerebrospinal fluid or CSF
it allows a transmigration of monocytes
and leukocytes into the central nervous
system
so for immune Signori it can recruit
monocytes and leukocytes infection
hemorrhage and stroke so if you have
brain damage that can actually signal up
the peripheral immune system and request
additional cells to come help out with
any damage in the brain it's also
responsible for the diffusion and
transport of drugs as I previously
mentioned and like I said some of our
earlier work it's a reservoir for HIV
since HIV associated neurocognitive is
ordered disorders are the result of
infected cells entering the central
nervous system other to be a Trojan
heard or Trojan horse model having a
cord plexus epithelial cell model would
allow us to study the barrier properties
at one of the last lines of defense
between the blood and the cerebrospinal
fluid in the central nervous system so
that's kind of what got me interested in
the koi plexus and studying it and
figuring out why so like I said we
sought of thought to figure out a way to
create a Cori plexus epithelial cell
culture
now when you're designing a primary cell
culture you have to keep a lot of things
in mind you want to know what cells
you're looking for you have a couple
different types epithelial like
fibroblast like lymphoblast
like and those types all have different
needs in culture you also need to know
the type of substrate
whether that can just sit on the petri
dishes or if you need gelatin collagen
or maître gel you also have to use
sterile conditions when you're using
your cell culture to prevent bacterial
and fungal contamination which can
completely ruin your culture you also
need to know what type of food or media
the cells need in order to grow and
survive these can include things like
different amino acids carbohydrates
vitamins and minerals growth factors to
help promote growth and even hormones
and also you need to have culture
positions like when they're in an
incubator what concentration of gasses
you need pH osmotic pressure and even
the temperature the cells needs to grow
so there are a lot of different factors
to think about
now if you curious about this and you
want to learn more give Co has some
great background stuff they have the so
culture basics handbook and an online
interactive lab which are both free and
awesome and I actually used both when I
first started out trying to figure out
how to design my own cell culture so to
get practice before you actually get in
the lab and do stuff I do highly
recommend these resources so since we
knew we wanted epithelial cells there
pulley can roll in shape they need a
substrate to attach to so we listed the
three different types these are just
some goofy pictures I got we have
gelatin this is a picture of jello
because it's the closest thing gelatin
is just sort of this clear boring goop
so figured picture of gel is a lot more
fun you'll have collagen so here's a
picture of collagen matrix and then
here's a picture of the actual matrix to
symbolize nature gel which is the more
extreme really nice substrate with which
to grow so cool chicken so since our lab
already does a lot of cell culture work
we grow both brain micro vascular
endothelial cells and astrocytes we kind
of had an idea of what media we're going
to need to grow brain cells and after a
lot of playing around with different
types of media like dmem and 1-99 we
settled on m 199 we added some
additional l-glutamine which is a nope
losing my spot it's an amino acid energy
source for the cell and you need that
for them to grow and m109 also has Earl
salts and a phenol red peach indicator
so you could follow the pH in the cells
and see if the cultures are going well
that's why we chose M 199 and we also
added an anti anti which is an anti
mycotic and antibacterial thing to help
prevent the growth of contaminants in
our cell culture which n would
completely ruin them and then we also
use fetal bovine serum we use exosome
depleted if you go bovine serum to have
a really a pure
FBS to add to our cultures to help the
cells grow
there's a lot of trial and error
involved in this culture and I killed
several different cultures before we
actually got the full he started but
once we figured out the ideal substrate
and growing conditions and the media and
additional supplements we needed to grow
and about the first week after plating
the cells after a digestion we started
to see the cells attached and colonies
begin to form and as you can see in the
left you've got a colony of about five
cuboidal like cells that are forming a
little baby colony and on the right it's
a little bit harder to see but you have
a slightly larger colony there was a lot
of inner animal differences depending on
the seating density with which you
played the initial cells how long it
took to attach like 24 to 48 hours the
collagen substrate could all affect how
quickly these cultures grew now in two
to three weeks you start to see these
colonies expand and spread out and again
their political cuboidal like cells
which are definitely epithelial like in
nature so it's kind of what we were
expecting to see in our cultures
took about four to eight weeks again
depending on animal variation feeding
density things like that we first
started but within four to eight weeks
the place began to become confluent we
are worried a little bit about
fiberglass contamination as you will
with most cell cultures so if you saw I
mean it started to kind of look like
fibroblasts growing in the cultures we
treated with something called sis for
hydroxy d prolene or sis HP which has
previously been published to be a
fibroblast treatment so we use that if
necessary to take care of fibroblast
contamination so once you reach
confluence the next episode see hey this
is a primary cell culture am I able to
subculture this and keep dividing it and
make more well to it so we were able to
successfully subculture you can kind of
see in the top left out there's that
like little corner that's because this
is a collagen coded little disc that we
put inside the wells so that we grow the
cells on these discs and then we get to
fix them and then sting them to confirm
the identity because yes b-cells are
epithelial like in nature we can't
conclusively say that their choroid
plexus epithelial cells at this point
the next thing we have do again validate
them and confirm their identity now we
can do this by finding literature
reported markers for the cells of choice
so we used clothes Oh which is an
anti-aging hormone transfer rate which
is a binding person that transports
thyroxine and retinol and the
capitalized letters are how it got its
name we also use by mention and
phalloidin if I mention is an
intermediate filament protein and fluid
in stains f-actin so those are both
structural proteins to you know really
show that we've got this cuboidal and
polygonal like so and we also use zhonya
lagoons one orzo one which identifies
tight Junction proteins now if you
remember from the quarry plexus pictures
from way back corvax is also known for
having tight junctions between the
single layer epithelial cell around the
outside so ideally we would like to see
though one in these cultures we also
want to look at focal adhesion kinase
which identifies cell to cell adhesion
you also have to them to do truce and to
say hey you know what I've got is
correct
you also do I set controls to make sure
there's no nonspecific binding of your
antibodies to anything in your cells you
always do I set controls to make sure
that the standing you're seeing from all
the above antibodies are true you also
want to exclude other cell types when
you're confirming your identity like
neurons astrocytes microglia and even
macrophages now thankfully for us there
are no neurons in the Corey plexus that
ruled out that cell type but you also
have after types so we stained 4GS ap
microglia which we looked for for I
belong as well as macrophages for C D
163 so this is how you would go through
to confirm to say that hey we've got
this the cells of the shape that we want
the morphology that we want think these
are it let's confirm by making sure it
stands for true markers the markers are
true staining as and it doesn't bind to
nonspecific binding in the background
and then you also exclude other cell
types and at that point you're kind of
like narrowing it down as I hey this is
the cell type that I want and I've got
the correct type
so here's an example of our closest
standing and again close the anti-aging
hormone I forgot
the legend on the right listen different
colors didn't think about this ahead of
time I do apologize if you are red-green
color blind because I put clothes on
phalloidin and red and green so I do
apologize about that but close oh is the
red stain that is perinuclear to the
blue Dappy and then saluton again is the
structural protein that kind of just
shows the shape of these cells and as
you can see all of the cells here were
positive for both clothes oh and Debbie
all right phalloidin and Gaby so you do
see the cells and they are piled
difficult though and Floyd and which
just kind of give you the shape and also
show you that they are positive for a
marker of the choroid plexus and next we
look at transpire and Appy it's a little
bit more of a fainter stain on the
screen again with the ice tech controls
this was true staining as you can see
here the cells were positive for trans
citrate which is in green and then the
Dappy in blue so you can see the kind of
again cuboidal cells that are positive
for trans I've eaten it's up there
little gap in nuclei in the center then
we look at the structural proteins again
you've got the by medicine and the
phalloidin phalloidin again it's in blue
so kind of the blue squares at the
forward and standing and the DAP in the
center is the nuclei circles and if I
mention is red you can kind of see the
structure in the shape and even the
active and the filaments in these cells
which is super super cool
here was my combined image that supposed
to transpire eaten I mentioned
phalloidin adapting it's one of my
favorite pictures cause you have that
nice cuboidal cell in the center of the
picture so you've got all the positives
for the standings that we're looking for
plus it's got the shape it's really
looking like we had identified choroid
plexus epithelial cells the next thing
we wanted to do was look at is o1 or the
tight Junction proteins and as you can
see right up increase the brightness
just so you can see it just a little bit
better on the screen since it is tinier
with the PowerPoint you can see the
Dappy nuclei in the center and as you
can look around a lot of these cells use
bright red kind of dots you're able to
zoom in you see these nice lines and
this is indicating the tight junctions
that are forming between the
that's zone 1 staining three cells had
formed tight junctions with each other
again indicating quarry plush epithelial
like features and then again we looked
at supplication kindness if you can't
look to the bottom left you a really
great example of two we see those look
like red spikes coming off with those
and that's actually where they've formed
adhesions are trying to form occasions
with adjacent cells so as of right now
they are all positive for all of it so
you think all the knowledge that we have
the right morphology and we have all
these positive stains it's really looks
like we have cords biceps a little
something at this point we can
definitely say that the cells that we
got from the choroid plexus and are
positive for all of these markers
negative for ric type or an upside the
truth painting for our eyesight controls
and it was negative for astrocytes
microglia and sacrifices that we do know
that we've got choroid plexus epithelial
cells so this is our 2d culture now
there are some differences between 2d
and 3d cell culture and a lot of our
other present presenters do you want to
go back and look at some of their
presentations they really did talk about
the differences between 2d and 3d
culture so I didn't want to give you a
little bit more of a background on the
differences between 2d and 3d so 2d is
simple easy to do across the sector
however it doesn't really mimic in vivo
and the cells not only interact like the
only interaction with the plug the
plastic in the edges of the plate they
don't really interact as much with each
other in the matrix we also don't have
gradients for a micro environment now 3d
is a little bit harder to do complex
will the less cost effective but it's a
better in vivo representation it can
show self cell interactions and
extracellular matrix interactions and
you can also look at gradients and the
micro environment this is a really
popular model to use in cancer biology
and tumor biology because you can create
it's alike organoids and actual tumors
and culture so the cord plexus has a lot
of different cell types going on and we
were really just more interested in the
barrier properties in that single layer
of epithelial cells we kind of wanted to
do a modified 3d I'm calling it 2.5
because they wanted something simple and
cost-effective but we want to be able to
represent you know the individual
representation of the barrier properties
of the movement and the gradients across
this Koree plexus epithelial cell
barrier so we decided to work on this
modified 3d and we use trans well
inserts in these petri dishes where we
actually related cells and these trans
will insert in the center and we could
add maybe on the outside world and the
inside walls but kind of at this point
wanted to see the fusion properties and
weather media could move across if we
could form a barrier and if the media
could move across set barrier and as you
can see I did a little bit of a lower
level of media on the outside wall and
in the inner well you can see how the
media is a little bit higher because I
added more into that Center well
as you can see here a little bit I
didn't take a really good picture you
can see how the media levels have
actually leveled out so there was
movement of media across and they
leveled out so both the medium the inner
and outer walls right equal levels
indicated there was the impermeability
and diffusion of this liquid across we
really wanted to know how good these
barrier properties were and you can't
really do that by just looking at a
microscope at these trans buttons you
can't really look at the properties of
this barrier so that was to working with
our next thing this is the excel dense
model I did just want to clarify the
very beginning that thermo Fisher and
GUID codes do not endorse excel gence in
our aura stoner AC e Biosciences this
stuff is presented because it's how I
use the model how data was analyzed it's
a very specific device and you'll see as
I'm going forward on why I just had to
present this data in this just if I did
want to clarify that in the very
beginning so rexella gence is a
real-time label free cell monitoring
system so you've got these little 16
mile plates and they found electrodes in
the bottom of these plates so well at
the picture on the left is a schematic
of one of the wells now you can run an
electron flow through the well and I'll
move from the negative to the positive
terminal and when there are no cells
present there's no impedance so you have
a nice unimpeded electron flow when you
add cells moving to the right picture
and the cells attachment adhere to the
substrate you start to get an impeded
electron flow as the cells attach to
making it harder for the electron
current to move from the left the
negative terminal to the positive
terminal the right so that's the model
design with it and one of the readouts
that you'll see from the excel gents
device was just taking this data and
using the initial cell index with which
you plated it will calculate using the
apenas 2 we can calculate the southern
accent and the increases you'll see
based on the cells you've added so this
is an example of what a trace would look
like on the device so when you first add
the cells you'll see this rapid increase
in the trace as the cells begin to
adhere and impede the electron flow you
start to have a slower increase due to
the cell proliferation kind of in the
middle especially the slower growing
cell line and then you'll get a plateau
once the cells have reach confluence and
really blocked the electron flow through
the culture and that is your baseline
like cell barrier you can then add
different experimental treatments in
this case they added a napa ptosis
inducer and as you can see here when you
see that stark drop in the trace it's a
decrease due to sell the tech death or
detachment and i can actually show you
barrier properties at the top when you
have the plateau you've got a nice tight
barrier when you start to see the traces
drop off it's indicating that there is
damage to the barrier whether it's due
to cell death or detachment something is
disturbing the barrier properties so
here is an example of one of my models
this is just an example of appearances
again it's real time a super nice
feature that I could put the cells in
let it grow over time go home and sleep
come back work on it the next day so you
can see at the bottom on the y-axis this
is done in hours and this is about 160
hours throughout several days with this
specific experiment as you can see
there's an examples of plateau when our
experiment reached confluent and then
here these will these little spikes are
when I pause the machine to pull out the
plate to add whatever experimental
conditions those are what those little
Peaks are moving forward
so here is a zoomed in picture of our
barrier and our confluence as you can
see you see that rapid cell growth as
you go from the zero when there are no
cells attached and adhere to both when
they are adhering and then you have that
plateau this is a really great nice
plateau showing that the cells had
attached and adhered bottom of the plate
you have some nice barrier properties
here we actually had created a usable
barrier so our next step we're kind of
curious so when HIV going back to the
day I talked about before with HIV when
it first enters the central nervous
system there's some argument about
Trojan her a Trojan horse but either way
the infected cells cause a weakening of
the choroid plexus barrier which can
allow more movement of infected cells
into the choroid plexus and into the
central central nervous system tannaz
alpha is a pro-inflammatory cytokine
that can be secreted by both macrophages
and even endothelial cells if an HIV
infected modified crosses the
fenestrated endothelium inside the
choroid plexus in normal immune
surveillance and triggers the release of
TNF alpha or even encounters a
macrophage inside the choroid plexus
which triggers the release of TNF alpha
we wanted to see if that dangerous
signal could then weaken the coroplast
epithelial cell barrier this could be
one explanation for how infected cells
enter the CMS and trigger that increase
in movement and settled across the cord
Price's barrier when you have more
infected cells and more damage in the
brain especially the leak your barrier
and more likely to have a more severe
presentation of HIV associated
neurocognitive disorders that's where
this was really important to us to look
at the pro-inflammatory challenge so
it's a lot going on in this picture but
the blue and the pink lives very top
those the cord plexus plus just media
control measurements now as you can see
it stays around zero i baseline this out
since that is our control and the red
and green were cell cultures we're at
the very beginning on the left of the
graph
I added TNF alpha the pro-inflammatory
cytokine as you can see both the red and
green traces star should drop off if you
think about our graph in a few seconds
earlier with the concept
excelence when you start to see that
decrease in trace it indicates that
there is cell detachment or death but
damage to the barrier function so tan of
alpha didn't be damaged our quarry
plexus barrier properties and this
little spike here around it looks like
1990 hours 1.4 it's a very tiny screen
I'm still a little new blip where it
lifts up and drops off again the more
times you challenged with tnf-alpha the
worse the barrier properties becomes the
more pro-inflammatory challenges you
have the barrier really gets damaged so
we did indicate that a pro-inflammatory
cytokine kind could affect our quad
placement athelia cell barrier so the
next thing we wanted to do we want to
repeat the experiment with a
pro-inflammatory challenge but then we
wanted to follow it with an
anti-inflammatory challenge we decided
to use steroids and steroids or our
anti-inflammatory and we wanted to see
if we could reverse the damage caused by
the inflammatory cytokine Tina salsa so
here again this is a really busy graph
but the pink and blue traces in the very
beginning on the left side so you have a
the line dividing the graph if you look
to the left side of that the left side
of the TNF alpha challenge so in the top
part on the left you see the pink and
the blue and those are the choroid
plexus plus just what perplexes push me
it's just Cori plexus at that point in
this graph and right below it in the red
and the green you see the Corey plexus
plus TNF alpha now once you move past
identifiers lines in the middle you move
to the right you actually for different
conditions because we took half of the
control wells and half of the tnf-alpha
wells and we added dexamethasone a
steroid now as you can see the top
picture is pink which is quite by system
dexamethasone blue is just the choroid
plexus plus media green is Cori plexus
plus the TNF alpha and dexamethasone and
then red is the choroid plexus plus TNF
alpha as you can see here again red is
the worst at support plexus plus the
pro-inflammatory cytokine with no
steroidal treatment but when you look at
green
asked about Mills divider line once we
started adding dexamethasone to those
wells you actually see an increase with
each subsequent administration of
dexamethasone the extra see an increase
in the barrier properties on the sell
index of these wells initiated
dexamethasone was helping to repair the
barrier properties of these wells again
blue that's going to be kind of our
baseline and another interesting thing
when you just look at the baseline the
court plexus plus just dexamethasone
just to rule out any other effects of
dexamethasone on the cells by themselves
you do see an increase in barrier
function so that's another zone did
slightly help tighten the barrier of
just plain cord plexus cells without TNF
alpha but it's still really interesting
to note that dexamethasone was able to
repair some of the barrier function in
TNF damaged cells and affected selves as
possibly this is one explanation why
there is like with the TNF alpha whether
is some weakness the blood-brain barrier
or the blood CSF barrier and why
infected cells could actually trigger
the weakening of the bear and this is
promising because maybe this story
treatment or even any other kind of
anti-inflammatory treatment might be
helpful in patients suffering from HIV
associated neurocognitive disorders so
for some conclusions interview cell a
pertinent global health crisis this is
due to the long-lived viral reservoirs
in which the brain and the choroid
plexus are one the choroid plexus is
really important because it's an immune
interface with the monocyte trafficking
and barrier dysfunction seen in HIV
associated neurocognitive disorders as
well and other diseases too so it's
really important to study the choroid
plexus epithelial cell barrier i forgot
to mention this way way way at the
beginning but the reason why my culture
is important because we did this in
rhesus macaques
those are primates and they're one of
the ideal models of studying HIV in
animals and so while I do have some rat
and pigs Cory plexus epithelial cell
cultured out in the market
rhesus macaque so the better model for
this specific study with HIV so that's
why we were set about to create this
quarter-sized epithelial cell barrier
again the core applies to epithelial
cells as the last part of a defense
especially on HIV infections we were
curious in creating an epithelial cell
barrier and so we created a 2d Croatia's
epithelial cell culture we validated
that by the pathology the choroid plexus
epithelial cell markers and tight
junctions also the cord slices
epithelial cell modified 3d culture
allows us to study the barrier functions
of the Cori plexus in real-time we are
able to see that the pro-inflammatory
TNF alpha impairs Cori plexus epithelial
cell barrier potentially explaining why
we have increases in infected cells into
the central nervous system also the
anti-inflammatory dexamethasone returns
barrier function after pro-inflammatory
challenge so it's in future directions I
want to continue to work on this
modified 3d cell culture model
especially in terms of HIV and actually
look at HIV the effects on this model
these are other applications to other
diseases other conditions other viruses
bacteria etc I also want to send the
permeability permeability more and see
maybe drug diffusion things like that
this work is in revision in frontiers so
I'm super excited about that and then
hopefully from your learning objectives
you were able to understand the history
development and function of the blood
CSF barrier the choroid plexus and
understand the pathology and therapeutic
potential of the cords like this it's a
really under study region of the brain
and it's obviously my favorite part of
their brain so I do hope you know
appreciate it a little bit more now and
then also to how to design a 2d and
modified 3d Cori flexed epithelial cell
model system and I'd like to acknowledge
everyone at the primate research center
who really helped out with this project
and so quick or things like that
dr. Maclean's lab who was my PI for my
PhD as well as Marcela Kuroda and Mookie
Kim who were advisors on my PhD I don't
like to thank thermo Fisher and good Co
scientific for selecting me for this
honor and thank you so much for Chelsea
and Christy for all of their hard work
and getting this together and making
sure I met my deadlines and turning
things and I also want to thank my
current ti LSU and then all teachers and
professors I've had in my training who
really got me to this point in my career
so thank you again thank you guys for
your time and if you guys have any
questions I will be happy to take them
thank you dr. delery for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar and if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
now those questions we are unable to
answer live today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
answered via the email address you
provided at the time of registration ok
dr. delery let's get started our first
question what kind of neural progenitor
does the CP produce that is an excellent
question so there's been a lot of papers
out recently talking about neural
progenitor niche found in the choroid
plexus and that's still kind of a newer
field like I'm not really sure what
types are leaning more towards like
radial glial cells like Galil and
astrocytes cells like one paper from a
group in Japan talked about how they
were able to take these neural
progenitor stem cells from the cord
plexus and implant it into a damaged
spinal cord and these cells actually
differentiated into astrocytes so they
were thinking it turns into either
oxidiser glial cells depending on the
signals from the surrounding area and
like danger associated molecular paths
our patterns things like that can
actually trigger the differentiation
into different cell types depending on
the need from the central nervous system
so that is that question there are a lot
of really good papers out there too if
you're interested in reading more about
it um they also argue it's there's age
dependent markers because that can
affect us and as the neural progenitor
cells stem cells decrease with age and a
really good paper is age dependent niche
signals from the choroid plexus regulate
adult neural stem cells by Vargas at all
if you'd really want to read more about
that so next question yes thank you dr.
delery is it barrier function or cell
population that you are looking at so
originally we were looking at cell
population we wanted to look at the
epithelial cells and lift that led to
more barrier function to see since
that's like the last line of this
between pathogens in the central nervous
system they first have to cross the
fenestrated capillaries and since we're
discussing this I do want to apologize
quickly there were some hiccups in the
slides
especially when it's showing the choroid
plexus just so you guys weren't able to
see what it looks like so with this
question we're talking about Barre
function let me pull up that so you can
see it - there's the glitch and loading
the animations so as you can see here
it's lining the big ventricles of the
brain and then also here's an example of
the fenestrated capillaries and cord
plexus and again on the next page which
rope which look more at the barrier
function if you look right here next
okay so here you see the fenestrated
capillaries and then choroidal
epithelium now for a pathogen to get
into the central nervous system it's got
a first cross and fenestrated
capillaries in this center go through
the stroma and pass through all the
immune cells of the stroma and then exit
the choroidal epithelial cells into the
CSF in the ventricles and so that's why
we started looking at barrier function
more because it's kind of like the last
one defense before moving into the
actual central nervous system but we are
kind of hoping to use this more as like
a true 3d model and make more of a
stromal like layer on top but we're
still playing around with that so
hopefully we'll be able to do that in
the near future on next question yes now
there's questions two parts how is our
you control for contamination and if
your plates got contaminated from
necropsy necropsy what did you do great
question okay so knee cropsy is actually
a super s basically an animal version of
an autopsy is when you're dissecting the
animal and it's a very big dirty
environment while we do wear PPE and we
are protected we have a dedicated suite
for the necropsy of the primates you
have multiple pathologists and vests in
there pulling out different tissues for
different testing types and it's
possible to get fecal matter from one
area of the body up into the choroid
plexus when you're trying to pull it out
of the brain and so it's very easy to
come contaminated with bacteria so we
control for
Tama nation by one having a sterile
environment as possible wearing the
proper PPE and extracting the choroid
plexus first before doing other parts of
the necropsy to fur collection of tissue
we processed it in a sterile hood a
major we sterilize it every time we used
it and then we also if it seemed like it
was been contaminated we added
additional antibacterials or anti my cot
X like promotion and fungi's own if we
really needed to supplement the media to
make sure contaminants didn't grow
that's a great question
now dr. delery how is the coy plexus
taken perfect so like I mentioned with
miecraft see they cut the skull open and
you're able to pull out the core applies
it looks like this kind of like red
string inside the brain and back in the
back by the occipital lobe you actually
will see part of it and a pathologist
we have veterinary pathologists who are
skilled at to the brain in different
parts of body and they were able to pull
out the red string of the choroid plexus
and put into a tube of PBF of us next
question yes now why not studies here in
order to study barrier function in terms
of resistance via the endothelial layer
poses to systemic circulation
okay so that's an excellent question we
looked at the epithelial layer rather
than the endothelial layer and basically
I was a graduate student so I used what
we had available to us and at the time
the priority said I did not have tier
setup so I used what was available to us
and what we had supplies for but it's a
great question on a technology I could
use in the future should I have access
to it but I was basically using
previously studied models that my P I
had used and equipment he had already
because I didn't really have time to
write a grant to get more funding from
the NIH for more equipment but that is
an excellent suggestion for future
testing
dr. gel er can you elaborate on why you
couldn't use human choroid plexus that's
awesome okay so you can't use human
choroid plexus because the only samples
I get I don't really know anyone out
there who would voluntarily submit to an
open brain surgery where we would remove
pieces of their choroid plexus and they
have they do actually have I believe a
human line out there however it was
taken from a patient who had cancer in
his core ID plexus and that can affect
growth rates of the cells and behavior
of cells so we didn't want to use that
just because it had it might have
different properties in a true normal
Corre plexus since it was cancerous
that's why we saved the next best model
the primate model
thank you dr. delery now after
extracting the choroid plexus the do you
dissociate it into individual cells
before culturing or do you put the whole
string in the media excellent question
so yes actually we did we
mechanically dissociated it we chopped
it up with a scalpel until we had little
pieces of it and then we also use a
digestion collagenous disc based
solution to help break it up a little
bit more it was easier if cells attached
in clusters because we didn't dissociate
it really well they actually grew a
little bit better but if you put whole
Corie plexus chunks in there it also
just didn't grow well so it's kind of
that fine line in between and we do have
a paper coming out that's currently in
revision that we'll have a more detailed
methodology to so if you're interested
in that you must follow up with me I
should hopefully be out the next couple
of months or shoot me an email it was on
the very first slide let me pull it back
up right now actually so you guys can
get it you're more than welcome to
submit your questions through thermo
Fisher and give Co or email me and ask
me any questions or if you just want to
say hey send me the paper when it gets
published and I would be more than happy
to do that
thank you dr. delery we've got some
great questions coming in we have time
for a few more and let's go with this
one it's come in several times how many
replicates were done with the X elegent
studies Oh awesome question um so Forex
elegance we're lucky in that it's a
sixteen well plate and as you remember
from some of the pictures when we pull
ups I can show you right now did you you
can see four lines here and obviously 16
divided by 4 is 4 so we have 4 separate
wells for each condition they were
averaged together to produce these lines
kind of when you see this you see the
the long vertical lines here that's
actually the standard deviation on the
graph they were a little bit Messier for
some of the other ones which is why I
wanted to do just the lines themselves
but those 4 replicates for that one
right there and I know replicates are
kind of an if you subject because you
mean replicates of animals or do you
mean replicates of studies were repeated
the Tanith alpha studies and
dexamethasone studies with a couple
other animals to believe is three with
TNF alpha two with dexamethasone so in
addition to multiple wells for each
animal we did have more than one animal
to practice it in again a lot of people
who work with mice are going to be upset
by the fact that we are only able to do
five primates for all of these studies
we've done more sense than but just for
this that the paper topic we did about
five primates just because they are a
select resource and more scarce than
mice and also way more expensive to
house for a year than mice so use our
available resources and an appropriate
and full of primate studies
thank you now our next question how are
you using this in your current studies
okay so I've kind of moved a little bit
from the HIV studies I'm not saying
neurobiology of alcoholism and inflamed
Ozone's
and opiates in the brain and actually as
you know alcohol and opiates hatch
across the central nervous system or
across the blood-brain barrier and blood
CSF barrier to enter the central nervous
system so I'm working that into my pis
grants and also submitting one of my own
grants later this year to start looking
at the cord places more in relation to
other conditions and other disorders and
having a primary cell culture that
allows me to do additional testing on is
fantastic and we have some frozen
cultures see that we're going to work
with in the future so I'm excited to see
if I can expand on this barrier
properties to study opiates alcohol
things like that
dr. Geller you were excited to see this
too and we'd love to know how do you
what do you hope to accomplish with this
ideally um so I know this is a really
epic for a lot of people but animal
research if you're familiar with the US
aya kook laws the goal is to reduce
replace and like limit the number of
animals you use replace it with more
simple models because we want to make
sure they have the most humane care and
we're not causing undue suffering or
anything like that and while I realize
it's a necessary step in pharmacological
testing you know disease modeling things
like that I would like to have create
ways that we limit the number of animals
that we use and so I hope that this
culture can be used to study conditions
ex vivo it would also limit the number
of primates that would have to be
experimented on whether it's you know
drug delivery or the effects of drugs on
the blood CSF barrier etc I'd love to
use this model to help one you know
humankind increased quality of life but
also limit the amount of animals we use
in studies so that's my hope for this
model going forward
thank you dr. gallery now do you have
any final comments for our audience
no I'm thank you guys so much for tuning
in today to watch this and again you
know please reach out to me on my email
again it's listed right here too and
then social media I would love to know
things you want to learn about things
you want to talk about if you're
watching and you're applying to grad
school soon feel free to let me know if
you need any help or advice going
forward or picking a dissertation topic
or a pie or whatever I'm still fairly
new to the post game so not too far away
from the PhD that I can't provide advice
if you guys need it and again just get
out there and the love science we love
what you guys do and feel free to reach
out to me and connect with me on
Instagram or LinkedIn I believe I'm the
only or like the top Elisabeth delery on
LinkedIn right now so feel free to reach
out to me on social media
a big thank you again to dr. Elizabeth
delery for her time today and her
important research I'd also like to
thank Bob Rhodes and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast now before
we go I want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions again just to
reminder those questions we did not have
time to answer today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by dr. delery via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand and labret swil alert you
shortwave via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with all your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
thanks for joining us today and we hope
to see you again soon bye bye